I just love the idea of this poor
casting director going Les don't be
McKay repeat what did I just say and in
the end just getting so bored scrub just
gonna send it I had like I my manw was
saying no you cannot take this do not
take this this is no you're gonna be
you'll be out of commission for five
years or whatever I'm like uh working
yeah working for five years in the genre
that I love um you know so there's all
they're always trying to maneuver and
stuff it's very weird whoever his
manager is I actually want to punch them
in the testicles with a ice pick don't
punch with an ice pick but you know what
I mean at that time Stargate sg1 was at
the height of its power what sort of a
manager would go that yeah don't go on
that highly successful franchise TV show
you idiot who would do that I to play a
character that's already popular I I
don't understand that mentality